The way I approached interviewing was that I left my ego at the door.
What Larry King thought about something really didn't matter...
...but the guest mattered.
I didn't know more about law than the lawyer,...
...I didn't know more about medicine than the doctor,...
...I didn't know more than my guest...
...and I respected the guest.
I could have disagreed.
But I wanted to be the conduit, from me.
If you're not giving your opinion, the guest is more comfortable...
...'cause you're more interested.
They're not there in a confrontational state...
...and I'm there to learn.
We made the front page of the New York Times,...
...I think more than any other talk show ever...
...because I was getting good quotes.
I also won a Peabody for the radio,...
...the only Peabody ever for a lifetime work on radio talk shows.
Why I never gave an opinion.